because i remember reading solo leveling
as well which is on paper the most
generic power fantasy show
ever and it sounds like it's up your
alley then of course of course
why would you love power fantasy one so
much i don't know because okay i i've
been in cell and he wants figure this
out it's because power fantasy shows to
me are like the term my brain off this
is act
this these shows are the ones that
activates my monkey brain
because i was for the longest time i
couldn't we all have a monkey break of
course
for like the longest time i couldn't
feel i couldn't figure out the appeal of
slice of life like a lot of people like
slice of life i've just never been able
to
get into i like slightly yeah and and
then i realized i think my mentality
when watching these
trashy isekai power fancy [ __ ] is the
same it's the same kind of mindset when
people have when i watch slice of life
which is just
switch my brain off and just you know
just enjoy what you're watching just
enjoy what i'm watching
because i like power fantasies give me
the minimal
amount of engagement just just the
minimal just enough to activate the
monkey brain but not enough to make me
think anything
is it is it like because you like the
idea that it could be you
in the powerful position is that why i
mean the biggest compliment yet biggest
disc
is no that's i mean that's why i call
them trash right yeah because i know
they're [ __ ] trash
but i don't watch them to engage myself
in any way shape or form
it's not a matter of like immersing
yourself because no no because i i know
how it feels to be like 15 and watching
sao and you're like god i wish that was
me yeah god i want to be serious i want
to be kiritos
i want to be so [ __ ] op and real yeah
yeah and then you realize [ __ ]
that's it's kind of like insulting yeah
that's
hella insane like all my problems would
be solved if i'm just better than
everyone else
you know what i mean like if they were
if they if this is a world that relies
on strength and i'm just disgustingly
overpowered it's like well
my life will just be easy yeah no one no
one can call me an [ __ ] or yeah you
know
alpha male way of thinking that yeah i
mean that's i think that's what it is
though like especially when you're
younger
oh yeah you think like oh my god i want
to grow up to be like yeah because
you're like okay well maybe i'm not
fitting in at school
like yeah i want to be saitama and [ __ ]
[ __ ] up yeah i bet he gets
ass if he wants it yeah no there's
there's there was definitely a point in
my
teenage hood and i think in a lot of
other people when they were teenagers
where yeah
we watch power fantasies because we want
to be the [ __ ] main character
um i think the appeal like there's
always there's always still that kind of
appeal
that i don't think i've ever lost that
really i i think i grew out of that i
don't know
i still i still have that with harry
manga yeah
well because when i was like grow up i
would i thought like when i was like 15
i thought tolavaro was like a gift from
god because i'm just like bro
i want to be rito so [ __ ] hard and
get all these girls yeah and now i
read to love her again i'm just like
yeah same
that feeling is still there dude it's
like he's like reading sweet guy you
know
he's like god that i wish that was me
like like you you get to see this guy
[ __ ] a load of girls and you're like
you know it's like oh i'm i'm feeling
the power fancy i felt when i was 15.
it's really it was really weird right
that's because you're in like very long
term relationships
you're like yes i just want to [ __ ]
everyone and not give a [ __ ]
no it's no it's just it's just
you've got to play that question real
safe voice
i mean he's like listening
[Laughter]
no but i feel like every like i feel
like a lot of guys never grow out of
that phase when they're a teenager
there's always a little bit of
teenager yeah every guy every guy and
girl keep breathing all right
everyone has that horny monkey brain
yeah like one show i've been really
enjoying recently has been a demon
school academy
which is which is power fantasy but it
takes it
but it takes it to another [ __ ] level
this guy is
like more opie than any other one is
that like the white head like
huge buff character is that no no no
it's or is that something else it's
uh i don't think about the really shitty
animated one the
tale of gary or something yeah yeah that
one
no it's like tale of like greg or
something like something like it's a
really white name
oh the ogres oh yeah
it was i can't remember it it's like the
tail right [ __ ]
yeah i know exactly what you're talking
about [ __ ] like clip art animation
all i remember is that he has the
whitest name in magic yeah he's like
it's like glenn
or like greg or something or something
yeah something like that yeah
it's the legend of gary oak but now this
guy from my deemed school academy he
he opens up the episode with him beating
up a guy to death with his heartbeat
and you're like this is so over the top
what's this this is going this is
this is like the most satirical
non-satirical
show i've ever seen he's it's he's so
opie that you're like
they they can't be taking this seriously
but it is it is like played off in the
series
totally seriously but the the situations
that themselves just feel satirical
because he dies about he's died about
three times in the shows
in the show now but he's so happy that
he's like you think that killing would
make me
would be enough to make me die oh yes i
have seen that
yeah i saw that meme yeah yeah and i'm
just like man
i'm enjoying the shows for like totally
different reasons
my monkey brain is like clapping now
this this is [ __ ] fantastic
it sounds like a parody of a white novel
you know like if i wanted to just like
[ __ ] around and just be like i'm going
to make the most generic
satirical just parody of a power fantasy
light novel
that would be the it's like it's like
kanye west the power fantasy light
novels because it's like it's
it's just become a parody of itself
yeah you know what power anime i really
enjoyed it was the one with that [ __ ]
i was gonna say the schools but that
doesn't help at all
uh the one with the it's a magical
school and he has no powers
you haven't narrowed it down at all okay
okay
it's different it's the one with the
guns he makes guns he's a famous gunman
he makes
guns yeah he makes guns in the show it's
it's like a certain magical
not a certain magical index it's like a
[ __ ] a certain magical high school or
some [ __ ] [ __ ]
but it sounds like it still sounds like
you're describing i'm [ __ ] losing my
mind here it sounds like you're
describing like
you just went from index to like [ __ ]
railgun now like
it's it's like [ __ ] similar vibes to
that is it an easy guy
no it's just it's just the power fantasy
who everyone thinks he's going to [ __ ]
his sister in the school
and he has he's not narrowing him down
now i know the one who's in the guns
is it the one with like the white the
white and the white and green
popular here yeah yeah you're not the
one i want about another one you're on
about yeah because
i think i think i don't know the formula
oh yeah the
the irregular high score that's it yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's what i said
before and you were like no no i was
talking about a different one at that
time
that was a harem anime this one is a
different one about a power fantasy
wait so what were you talking about
before no not that i was talking about a
difference i
i cleaned it up being like oh yeah the
one you're talking about before was the
irregular of magic
when we take our next two minute break
i'ma look it up because i'm frustrated
and i'm like okay we're done with the
regular music high school and you're
like what's the one that we've done
i wasn't talking about a regular magic
high school before i am now
joey that's a good show
of comment i just like the fact that
these shows are so generic
they're trying to distinguish between
them as we come in possible
so what did you like about that show
what did you like about the point you
were trying to make exact same shows
every year i'm sure
i don't know it was a good show i did
not enjoy that show because
again as you said it was exactly the
same as every other [ __ ] power for
some reason that shows
i i don't know it's so popular here yeah
i see it [ __ ]
i don't know why i i kind of get it
because i [ __ ] loved it i don't know
why i loved it but i loved it
it's so boring i'm like this is exactly
the same as every other light novel i've
heard yeah